يعد التأخير جزءًا أساسيًا من هاواي ،
وهو رمز يمتد إلى العصور القديمة
ولكنه ليس مقاسًا واحدًا يناسب الجميع
، وفي جميع أنحاء جزر هاواي ،
هناك العديد من صانعي الطبقات والعديد من أنماط
لي ، هذا هو بيل شار أسطورة في
لي هاواي التقليدي  جعل
الناس الأوائل يفعلون شيئًا بسيطًا للغاية ،
لم يكونوا
مثل هذه الأواني الملونة الرائعة مثل هذا اليوم ، هذا يتم فقط
باستخدام السرخس ، إنه كائن واحد تم تقييمه على
نفسه ، وكان الكثير منهم بسيطًا جدًا
مثل رقائق الفلفل الحار المستخدمة لأغراض رمزية
عندما تكون  صنع LA وهو
بمثابة العمود الفقري لعلاقاتك العائلية
وأنت تضيف كل زهرة
تشبه نوعًا ما شخصًا ابن عمك أختك
التي تضيفها إلى أخيك طوال الوقت الذي
تلتف فيه فوق السيقان التي تشكل
العمود الفقري لعائلتك
ويستمر الأمر ، وبعد ذلك يكون لديك
خطوط رحلات بحرية على أوراق الشجر مع
تلك الأيام الخوالي وسيأتي الناس
وسيحصلون على
أرجلهم وكان جزءًا من التقاليد أن تتوقف في
هاواي عندما توقفت ، حصلت على  التأخير
عندما بدأ السائحون في القدوم إلى
الجزر ، أصبح أسلوب الطريق الحجري المسمى Kui
شائعًا وكان الحي الصيني هو
المكان المناسب للحصول عليهم
أحد الأماكن العديدة في الحي الصيني
ويسمى متجر Cindy's lay and flower shop
منذ 50 عامًا في
البداية  ربما كان هناك
أربعة أو خمسة أنواع مختلفة من leis
الآن لديك 40 40 أو أكثر من 50 عامًا
مضت ، لا تزال الزهور تُصنع بنفس الطريقة التي يتم بها
تسليم الإبرة وخيط الزهور هنا ونقوم
بترتيبها ونقوم بترتيبها بشكل أفضل  يمكننا من
يصنع لي أن يبدو طبيعيًا أن صنع lei مفتوح
يتم تمريره من خلال
تقاليد الأسرة ويستمر في العثور على
تعبير جديد في الجيل التالي
وشمي أو جدتي كانت
صانعة غزيرة الإنتاج في هاواي ،
لقد ساعدتها في جعل lei جلست هناك و
نظفت أزهارها وحصلت للتو على
نوع من الانغماس في شغفها بـ
lei مما يجعل هناك العديد
من الأساليب المختلفة للدانتيل أنا شخصياً متخصص في
جعله رائعًا كم هو رائع
يتم ارتداؤها على رأسك تمامًا كما
لو كنت أرتدي وقتي ، وبعض
الناس يرتدونها حول عنقهم
وكيف يمكن أن يشير فقط إلى
النمط التقليدي لصنعها هنا نذهب ولديهم
الكثير من المواد المختلفة ومن ثم
عادةً في هاواي أنت  لا تحضر إلى
حفلة عيد ميلاد لا تحضر
حفل زفاف لا تحضر حفلة
استحمام الطفل بدون لوس أنجلوس لشخص ما.
هو
بالفعل جزء من هذا الدوري ، أعتقد
أن هذه واحدة من أفضل الطرق لقول
هدية من القلب ذات
ملمس زهري جميل وبصري خاص جدًا ،
فأنت تعلم أنه إذا كنت قد حصلت على
طبقة أو إذا كنت تقدم هدية لإيطاليا ،
فلديك اتصال مع هاواي.  وهاواي هي
التعبير النهائي لكثير من سكان
هاواي ، فلدينا روح فطرية ضائعة
كما تعلمون وهي
إقامة ترحيبية دافئة معي ، وتناول الطعام معي
ومشاركتها معي وأعتقد أن هذا يتجسد نوعًا ما
في LA
you
[الموسيقى]